meantime a local senior living facility
held its first vaccine clinic today
both residents and staff received the
covid 19 vaccine
bianca holman shares how they made it an
experience to remember
senior living facilities have been hit
hard by the coronavirus pandemic
some parents and grandparents haven't
hugged a loved one in over a year
due to social distancing guidelines as a
part of our most vulnerable populations
one assisted living facility is finally
getting the covet 19 vaccine
sunrise of henderson will be among the
first senior living centers
in the state of nevada to receive this
incredible drug
i'm very excited that the states and the
cdc have prioritized our industry
because we have
it has particularly impacted seniors and
so
it's it is an exciting day for sure
the folks at sunrise put a spin on
vaccine distribution
making it a fun celebration of life with
a sparkling cider toast
and a photo booth to capture this
historic moment the community's
executive director scott koza put on an
impromptu
drag performance for residents and team
members during the clinic
we've had less questions from our
residents and again i think because
they've done this they've they've
participated in vaccinations to
eradicate
polio and you know measles and monks and
so i think
um they've done this and they're they're
ready to roll up their sleeves because
they you know they want things to get
back to normal as well a recent sunrise
survey shows 92 percent of responding
residents and families
will probably or definitely get the
vaccine for themselves
kennedy says the facility will continue
social distancing and increase
cleaning measures to prevent the spread
of the coronavirus
reporting bianca holman 8 news now